wir sind heute auf der insel war in
norwegen
wir zeigen euch heute was es hier alles
gibt was ist das das ist ein ruderboot
und das ist ein steak ich laufe auf dem
steg das ist dass das ist ein paddel mit
dem paddel rudert man da kommt die tiere
die fähre bringt passagiere vom festland
zur insel und von der insel zum festland
vetere legt am hafen an
die brücke wurde heruntergelassen die
passagiere gehen von bord was ich dass
das sind algen die algen sind dunkelgrün
wann ist dass das ist ein rettungsring
mit dem rettungsring redet man münchen
aus dem wasser das ist eine schulklasse
auf einem boot
sie kommen gerade zurück von einem
ausflug was ist das das ist eine
rettungsweste eine rettungsweste zwei
rettungswesten die rettungsweste
verhindert dass man im wasser untergeht
das ist ein aquarium
was ist doch das ist ein weg
was ist das das ist eine schnecke das
ist ein netz mit dem netz fängt man
fische
was ist das
das ist ein fangkorb mit dem frankfurt
fängt man krabbeln
das ist der caj am kai liegen die boote
an susanne was ist das das ist eine boje
die monopole ist auf dem wasser und
zeigt an was unter wasser ist wie zum
beispiel ein netz dazu unser video aus
dem hafen von römer danke für zu schauen